claude gensac alors claude gensac vous
comment avez vous connu louis de funès
dans quelles circonstances et c'est une
amitié qui a été longue et des grandes
en oui mais je les ai connus surtout
quand il jouait d'abord avec marthe
mercadier monde y est le poulain dans le
après ma puce à l'oreille et puis nous
avons
nous sommes retrouvés à tourner tous les
deux dans la vie d'un honnête homme le
film de guitry où il jouait valet de
chambre et moi une femme de chambre nous
nous ouvrions des portes et nous
portions des petits déjeuners où les
amants et puis nous nous étions toujours
dans un petit coin parce qu'on regardait
sacha guitry et c'est là sur un plateau
ou tournelle sacha guitry
c'était une atmosphère de cathédrales
personnes lisent un mot on n'osait même
pas rire aux maux du maître et il y en
avait que deux pauvres cons dans un coin
qui se marrait et de temps en temps il
avait ses lunettes guitry et il était
comme ça et il nous regarde et il
trouvait ça très bien et alors blanc
riez tous les deux et puis après ils me
raccompagne à une petite petite voiture
mais vraiment je ne sais même plus ce
que c'était c'était quelque chose de
poussif et enfin quand même qu'ils
avaient quand même trois vitesses
or lui n'a jamais passé outre la
deuxième jamais je pleurerais de rire et
me disais tu as tort comme ça ça n'est
pas dangereux il faut dire qu'il avait
pas beaucoup de feux rouges mais ya pas
beaucoup de voitures n'ont plus cette
époque là et il s'arrêta carrément au
carrefour et puis il repartait après
quand il était sur qui avait aucune
voiture ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre
et puis après nous nous sommes perdus de
vue on se voyait comme ça des temps en
temps est ce que les rapports ont été
différent lorsque vous vous êtes
retrouvé pour la série des gendarmes ou
là déjà il avait
il était certes nous avons trouvé avant
les gendarmes
j'avais toujours joué des personnages
tragique dramatique et où des jeunes
premières idiote et jacques charon et
jean michel roussier m'ont demandé de
jouer avec eux la dame de chez maxim de
feydeau et louis est venu voir la pièce
et il y avait dans la pièce un comédien
maurice risch et qui jouait en même
temps qu'ils tournaient avec lui le jour
dans un fantômas nom dans le grand
restaurant et il a vu la pièce il me
dire au président je savais pas du tout
que tu joues et les trucs comique et
deux jours après maurice risch me dit
louis m'a demandé il va tourner après
oscar est il vrai que tu fasses des
essais et demande si par hasard tu
voudrais bien je vous jure que c'est
authentique
si tu voudrais bien jouer avec lui c'est
tout à fait lui alors ça si vous
connaissez les acteurs aussi aussi aussi
merveilleux que ça qu'ils ont tout aussi
délicat présenter les mois parce que il
y en a sûrement mais moi personnellement
le nord est
j'ai donc fait les essais et monia
molinaro a été d'accord et c'est comme
ça que j'ai commencé avec lui j'ai fait
les grandes vacances et après le
gendarme se marie
vous avez dit un confrère dans la
semaine la qui n'étaient pas toujours
très gai parce que trop sollicité
effrayés par son succès c'est à dire
parler par les gens qui le tirait par la
manche
il n'était pas effrayé par son succès
mais d'abord c'était essentiellement un
timide et puis l'avait toujours peur de
mal parler de dire des choses qu'il ne
fallait pas etc
et puis comment il était justement très
sollicités ils en avaient ils en avaient
un peu assez puis glisse avis et s était
de jouer que c'est au théâtre que ce
soit au cinéma c'était de jouer et le
reste pour lui c'était accessoiriser le
public c'est pas ça qui est l'intéresse
c'est me voir et si je me plaît c'est
parfait c'est tout qu'il était la
complicité qu'il y avait entre lui et
jean giraud car ils ont tourné ensemble
de nombreux films jean chéreau est
malheureusement mort il ya quelques mois
est ce qui est ce que les rapports ont
changé car on disait que louis de funès
de plus en plus travaillait au scénario
ou à la réalisation et que même son rêve
était de faire un film
ça m'est très difficile de parler de
jean girault et je m'en excuse mais je
dois dire que j'en avais au début des
films des gendarmes avaient beaucoup
d'idées et c'est a su très bien avec
jamie free de se servir de louis et puis
après louis voulait des choses plus
important en plus poussé et je ne
suivais pas toujours d'où les problèmes
qu'il y avait alors il préférait il
préférerait évidemment se trouvait lui
il faut dire il faut bien dire que très
souvent sur le plateau c'était louis qui
trouvait
c'était là comme isabelle égal à ce
niveau là c'était surtout les guildes et
trouver ce qu'il a été très très heureux
quand il a tourné la fare car c'était
quelque chose d'important aussi ça
c'était c'était pour lui c'est est
toujours très très important parce
molière parce que c'était pour lui
c'était le summum et il était très très
heureux de pouvoir tourner enfin ce film
grâce à christian fechner et ça a été
évidemment peut-être un peu moins bien
accueilli que que les films de gérard
oury cleu les gendarmes et parce que
c'était un autre de funès et puis il
faut bien dire que pour le public
molière ayant été travaillé par tous en
classe on n'a pas gardé un tellement
bons souvenirs en disait déjà s apprend
et
oui